okay let's talk about antivirals and
coronavirus there is a big conversation
about what type of therapeutic treatment
might best work for coronavirus until we
have a vaccine there are all sorts of
different things being tested using
convalescent plasma to put the
antibodies of recovered people into the
bodies of those who are sick there are
all sorts of different types of
medications but one is antivirals so
Ramez aveer is an antiviral that is
currently the subject of a number of
random randomized controlled trials Ave
again also known as favilla ver that's a
mouthful is another antiviral that's
being tested and what it is increasingly
looking like is that to get these
medications to work at their best
whatever the best will be we're probably
going to have to start administering
them much earlier in the disease
progression when the patient is less
sick and we're going to talk about why
in just a moment but just to sort of
orient the conversation there was this a
randomized controlled trial of Rome des
aveer we got the results from it last
week it was given to patients already in
serious enough condition to be
hospitalized about a thousand people
were part of this RCT there was a
placebo group and what the study found
was that the duration of the virus was
reduced by about 30% in the group that
received room des aveer compared to the
placebo group very good
that's something 30% is important we
know less about whether room des vir was
saving people who otherwise would have
died the results were not statistically
significant on the mortality but one
thing in general is that antivirals work
better when they're taken earlier and
this is it's not a problem per se but it
presents a challenge with room des vir
which I'll tell you about in a moment
but as a general rule antivirals work
better when they are taken earlier the
earlier the better look at the flu
influenza and Tamiflu Tamiflu is
recommended within 48 hours
of onset not if you've had it for days
not if you're so serious from the flu
that you have to be in the hospital
that's considered too late for Tamiflu
to work at its best ideally you start
Tamiflu within 12 hours of starting a
flu symptoms if not you want to start it
within 24 hours if not absolutely you
want to be on Tamiflu within 48 hours
and the reason why is inherent in how
antivirals work antivirals don't come in
and destroy the virus or kill the virus
so to speak antivirals prevent the virus
from replicating when we talk about
viral growth we're talking about not
only the spread of cases but you're
infom a Janu in you know you have two
viral cells in your body they replicate
and become 4 and then 8 and 16 and 32 I
think you sort of get the idea what the
antiviral does is it prevents the virus
from continuing to replicate while the
body can fight the virus the longer you
wait the larger the viral load in the
body when you introduce the antiviral
that's why you want to start it earlier
and that's why Ramdev severe may work
significantly better if we were giving
it to people earlier what's the problem
with that well the problem with room
deser vir and corona virus is that
Ramdas vir is an intravenous therapy
it's given at a hospital for people who
are not only well into the disease but
sick enough to already be hospitalized
there's also potentially room reservoir
supply issues but it would be very
difficult to give you know how do you
you can't give everybody your room des
aver pill as soon as they test positive
for corona virus there's also a limited
supply of hospital equipment to be doing
the IV infusions you need staff in order
to give IV medication there's not room
at hospitals to give everybody room des
vir intravenously as soon as they test
positive so this of course is all
assuming that it worked but these are
the conversations we're now having about
antivirals so the upside is that because
antivirals tend to work better when
given earlier the study that said from
des aveer shorten disease by 30%
we may be able to do way better than
that sick patients can do better with it
but early in the disease it may actually
do even more for people who have
coronavirus the downside is an IV drug
is start it's tough to start giving to
so many people and since it's done in a
hospital setting we don't have the space
nor the resources nor the staffing to
give everybody room des Avira when they
test positive maybe if the supply is
increased you could give everybody in
high-risk groups the medication if it
continues to prove effective and
meanwhile we're continuing to have other
room des of your trials it's been opened
up for emergency use by the FDA and
additionally we're also testing coletta
Caleta is a combination of two HIV drugs
Ave again is also being tested that's
another antiviral so that's the latest
but a growing conversation is maybe the
antivirals have to start earlier and
thus may be much more effective
hopefully there will be tests done of
that sooner than later